Someone, please help me.
That's how everyone asked for help, and I don't want to die yet.
Somehow I survived, and
then I thought I'd confess to her, and I
ran away.
He gave me information about the smoke, etc. on the verge of dying
I have to respond to that at the risk of my life
He was thinking of everyone more than himself To
be honest, I wanted to hear your voice for the last time
4 Help me
So when something happens to me, I'll ask for the scent,
or I'll never forgive anyone who makes me cry [Music] I won't forgive anyone who makes Kaori-chan cry
Yes,
I won't waste his feelings
either. Did you absolutely understand
? [Music] Is it an email from the king?
or is it
messed up
please forgive me please forgive me